we begin this half hour with some
stunning stunning images of food from
around the world the pink lady food
photography awards are now in their
second decade from highly stylized
pictures of
creations to images celebrating the
ritual of food in everyday life the
competition brings in thousands of
entries from across the globe raymie
innocencio shows us some of the best
from the harvest in china with fresh
noodles cooling in the wind
to a vineyard in spain celebrating the
fruits of labor
and to new york's central park but
reimagined with broccoli in a
miniaturized manhattan
these are some of the winners across 25
categories at this year's pink lady food
photography awards what makes for a
beautiful
memorable even delicious food photo it
generates a response you know whether
that's um joy and
um
looking like i would really love to eat
that food that's been shown to me or
it's sort of freaking my conscience
thousands of entries were submitted this
year across nearly 100 countries half
the world how many hours
did you use to go through all of these
photographs it's probably
100 hours this photo rose to beat them
all a food vendor consumed in smoke
caught mid-motion grilling his kebabs
over licking flames in kashmir on the
border of india in pakistan what first
popped out at you it was just the the
color and the life and the vitality of
that image i'm looking at the picture
now as i i talk and my my mouth is
watering as i do that because i can
almost smell and feel the heat and the
the flavors of that food while you were
saying that i have to admit that my
mouth was watering too
chakraborty is the man behind the
tantalizing winner
when you first heard that you won how
did you feel i was all over the world
actually i feel overjoyed photography is
my passion
chakraborty lost count of how many
photos he took and credits his wife with
choosing the winning shot
and this year's winning works don't just
evoke joy or wonder
others draw attention to crisis to raise
awareness
in ukraine lunchtime at this summer
military camp last year in the face of
russian aggression
and in dhaka a child collecting water in
the city's slums
yet food can also be a celebration of
progress like this winning photo of a
south african girl quietly eating fruit
at a table
marguerite olofsey won first prize in
the women's category
that picture represented the fruits of
our freedom this little girl represented
the youth the young country that is
united and showing the rest of the world
who we truly are a collection of images
that really do speak a thousand words
for cbs saturday morning raymie in
asensio london
so beautiful i'm i'm a little i'm a
little i'm touched by those images
in a way and seeing so many different
cultures it's a beautiful thing the one
picture representing freedom yes as they
said it's great
well now we're going